if you want a single poll that confirms
that America is rapidly crumbling
it is a very disturbing series of recent
polls almost all of which
have Herschel Walker leading Rafael
Warnock in Georgia this is such an
important race the incumbent Democratic
senator Rafael Warnock is being
challenged by former football player
Herschel Walker Herschel Walker can
barely speak he cannot coherently
explain his position and the reasoning
for his position on any issue he claims
to be against abortion period but has
now been caught urging multiple women
and paying for the abortions of multiple
women
and if you look at recent polls from
just the last week you have Walker
leading three of the four polls Walker
plus two Walker plus five Walker plus
three with Raphael Warnock up in one of
those polls New York Times Siena
and on average
Herschel Walker is now leading this race
imagine the humiliation it will mean to
the United States if Herschel Walker is
one of 100 senators all is not yet lost
make sure that you vote other races that
are not looking good the Cary Lake Race
in Arizona where lunatic big lie
conspiracy theorist Carrie Lake who
wanted to secede from the United States
at one point although now she denies it
she is leading Katie Hobbs in all of the
four latest polls plus four plus three
plus eleven and plus two on average
Kerry lake is now leading by almost four
points Kerry Lake could be the next
governor of Arizona
Vance versus Ryan JD Vance is now
leading or is tied in every recent poll
against Democratic Challenger a
democratic Contender Tim Ryan for the
Ohio Senate another very important race
for a little while it looked like maybe
uh Ryan was going to going to be right
in there now just about every poll has
JD van sleeting I hope that if you live
in Ohio you will be voting and in
Pennsylvania Senate race Oz versus
fetterman we are still trying to figure
out what is going on but it is as close
as it has been there is now an Insider
Advantage poll that has Oz leading
although on average and sadly these
polls
predate the debate between Oz and
fetterman so we don't really know what's
going on the momentum has certainly
shifted for Oz as you can see Oz is the
red line and just climbing climbing
climbing to where it is now a veritable
tie if you look at the 538 Senate
forecast for uh who is expected to
control the Senate it is now essentially
tied
what at one point was let me take a look
what at one point was
71 percent odds that Democrats would
keep control of the Senate that has
dropped 20 points and it is now
51.49 this is the lowest point for
Democrats controlling the Senate going
all the way back to what was it The Late
July summer period
this could very quickly become a
humiliating disaster for Democrats I
hope every single one of you plans to
vote I certainly do